the uncertainty of planning a meeting
between two unpredictable leaders it may
not happen quickly it may happen later
but this president is ready if
everything is on track State Department
officials say they're still targeting a
June 12th meeting in Singapore between
President Trump and Kim jong-un the
president claims North Korea is
coordinating with the u.s. on planning
despite threats to cancel the summit the
u.s. and North Korean officials will try
to agree on how Kim surrenders his
nuclear program what North Korea
receives in return and when it will
receive it a top State Department
diplomat has just floated a plan where
North Korea would offer a big down
payment according to Susan Thornton the
acting assistant secretary of state for
East Asian and Pacific affairs quote the
question is what could be front-loaded
in a process that's inevitably going to
go on for some time and then what would
be acceptable to the North Korean side
in return for that front-loading
Republican Senator Marco Rubio tweeted
this is why I will do all I can to
prevent Susan Thorton from ever being
confirmed as Assistant Secretary of
State for East Asian and Pacific affairs
she is in Tokyo undermining POTUS by
advocating for partial surrender of
nukes by North Korea as acceptable
though the State Department says
Thornton's full comments matched
Secretary of State Mike Pompeo position
what Susan Thornton was talking about is
very similar and the same thing to what
Secretary Pompeo spoke about and that is
that we would like to see a bigger
bolder different faster deal than the
kind of deals that have been proposed
before the State Department says the
United States wants an upfront
demonstration beyond promises from Kim
jong-un
that he is willing to surrender his
nuclear weapons the South Korean
government also a target of recent North
Korean complaints is offering to mediate
between the United States and North
Korea trying to ensure that this summit
between president Trump and kim
jeong-hoon actually happens